- I sometimes fantasize about Splinter,
he's Asian.
- He's a rat.
- He's a good father.
(upbeat music)
- "Bridesmaids" is an absolute
classic, "Girl's Trip."
You know, those films
really inspired this film
in the sense of debauchery,
unapologetic, in your face,
and like, you know,
breaking out of these boxes
that society has put us in.
- You know, I love
"Bruce Almighty" so much.
It makes me weep.
You know, I do love the
Austin Powers series.
Yeah, true millennial, yeah.
Don't ask Sabrina, because they're cuspy.
They're like, "Austin what?"
Children.
- Of course "Bridesmaids",
that's really one that,
it felt like it broke the mold.
It was like, it was at a
time where people were like,
"Are women funny?"
And it's like, yeah we are,
and it really felt like
it helped the cause
in terms of us being here on
the backs of movies like that.
- And I always like to take
it way back to "American Pie".
That was a movie that when
I saw this R-rated comedy,
it was a thing where I
saw it and then literally
24 hours later I got a bunch of my friends
to also go see it.
That's what we hope happens
with this movie as well,
and it really is so much more
fun to see a movie like this
in a theater with a bunch of friends,
with hundreds of people at once.
- I literally love "Bridesmaids"
and I love "Pitch Perfect".
Love "Girls Trip".
"Pitch Perfect" has a
special place in my heart
because when it came out,
I liked the movie so
much I literally thought
if I taught myself how to beatbox I could
maybe play the sibling
of the Asian beatboxer
in the first one in
sequels, and now here I am.
- I hate myself because the
first thing that I though of was
"Crazy Rich Asians" and
that's just like gross.
I mean comedy, "American Pie".
I saw Seth Rogen before, so
all the Seth Rogen movies
are on my mind.
I do enjoy comedies.
I like switching off into
something to laugh, so,
that's what we're doing tonight.
- I love Mel Brooks movies
and I love the Cohen brothers.
Those are kind of the funniest to me ever.
- "Pineapple Express" one
of my favorites, "Superbad".
Jackie Chan was a huge influence
in the beginning for me.
"Shanghai Noon", "Shanghai Nights",
"80 Days Around the World".
- "Midnight Run" is my, like,
favorite all time comedy.
I'm gonna stick with that
one. That's my movie.
- All of the "Fletch" movies,
which don't necessarily
age that well, but there
are still things about them
that are like, the timing is great.
"The Hangover", "Bringing Up Baby",
and "The Philadelphia Story".
- I grew up watching a lot
of comedies with my dad.
"The Breakfast Club", "Stripes", "Fletch",
"Caddyshack", "Overboard"
with Goldie Hawn.
Anything with Madeline Kahn.
"Young Frankenstein's"
one of my favorites.
Mel Brooks. "History of the World".
I miss those movies.